hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to would you rather now I
played will you press the button which
is a version of would you rather but
this is a legitimate online quickfire
game of would you rather that you can
actually play for yourself online right
now there's a link in the description
below that leads to the website but I'm
gonna start out with this very very very
very obvious one would you rather speak
every language except the language of
the country you're in or speak only the
language of the country you're in but
know the meaning of every single word in
that language oh no I would have to
travel around the world it'd be such a
curse to have to experience other
cultures and supposedly most people live
their life speaking only the language of
the country they're in and knowing half
of the words what's really the
difference duh thank you
what really why oh oh
maybe it's like no matter what country
go to you only you only speak every
other legs what that doesn't make sense
you still oh no you'd have to meet
people from other lands and speak their
language it would be amazing just a
thing you end the whole time I don't
care it's stupid I'm right they're wrong
this dumb next which you'd rather be
four feet tall or be ten feet tall
hey wait a minute I'm four foot two I
don't think you'd I'd rather be four
foot oh gosh oh no how horrible I'd be
ten feet III meant to click the form
anyway you're playing Kinect for against
an emotionally unstable man with an
explosive temper would you rather take
him down or let him win I'll take him
down he thinks he can take me on I own
him and Kinect for bring it oh well okay
a bunch of babies over here what a bunch
of losers
would you rather always speak all your
thoughts out loud or never speak at all
not even in sign language well I pretty
much speak all my thoughts anyway as
loud as I possibly can into every
microphone pointed in my face so I think
this is gonna be OK for my life
it's good enough for me I could probably
be a popular TV personality or in
politics topical jokes let's see would
you rather be forced to watch My Little
Pony for 24 hours or have the same theme
song stuck in your head for the rest of
your life oh god I mean technically if
you're forced to watch My Little Pony
for 24 hours oh not endlessly oh okay so
I don't want that stuck in my head for
the rest of my life I'd rather just get
it out of the way and watch it and then
move on that does not mean I'm no brony
I don't know in the comments section
let's just move on with this one because
apparently the majority agrees with me
because I wouldn't want to live with
that the rest of my goddamn life would
you rather die a hero or live long
enough to see yourself become a villain
oh this is that quote that I couldn't
get last video hmm I think I'd rather
die a hero
it all comes full circle hooray would
you rather be smart and unlucky or be
dumb and really lucky well I mean it
worked out for Forrest Gump so I don't
see why I wouldn't work out for me
oh come on guys come on
would you rather always be naked or
always be itchy I'm the only naked
wonder am I just always walking around
town fully clothed but very weird when I
go up to people I don't know I mean
people live their lives half-naked
anyway so why not why not commit let's
go full naked yeah everyone wants to be
naked I don't know if I'm too happy
about that one
wait this is kind of similar would you
rather live in a nudist colony or live
with the Amish again I have to go with
the nakedness
I mean I'm full on about the nudity
apparently people are learning a lot of
weird things about me
would you rather find five dollars or
having your local WNBA team win the
championship yeah let's go team oh come
on guys you you naughty people I don't
even know what my local WNBA team is but
how dare you would you rather watch an
uninterrupted WNBA double-header
listen to an entire Nickelback CD in one
sitting
really what's wrong with people who
would want to do that
I will admit though and I probably
shouldn't admit this cuz the comments
are gonna go crazy again don't mind some
Nickelback song would you rather be
Chinese or be Japanese well technically
speaking I'm Korean so this doesn't
necessarily apply to me eenie meenie
miney moe catch a tiger by the tail blah
blah blah blah blah Japanese oh man
people don't like to turn these would
you rather live in Beverly Hills rosu
copyright give me give me would you
rather live in a mansion in Beverly
Hills or a man penthouse in Manhattan
well considering that I live in LA I
guess I'd choose to be in Beverly Hills
so I wouldn't have to move very far so
yes oh wow very split so would you
rather live in New York or LA is the
question that I posed to you guys out
there would you rather be the president
or be a pokemon trainer okay now here's
where people are really gonna be mad at
me I don't like Pokemon I don't find
I'll hit all that fast I don't know why
people have such an obsession with it so
I'll take the president oh crap I'm
going to get roasted alive I'm sorry I
played pokemon red so basically I've
played every Pokemon game that's ever
come out it's true would you rather win
an Oscar win the Nobel Prize Nobel Prize
easy peasy
would you rather have to end every
sentence with a racial epithet or have
to drop two f-bombs in every sentence
well I kind of dropped the f-bombs
anyway so I think I'll take that route
oh and everyone agrees with me no one
wants to be a racist except 23 people
would you rather have a slight Lisp or
have a slight [ __ ] I I actually do have
a slight Lisp I will I have grown up
I've grown out I've got I can't talk
period is the answer to that one I
actually I actually have a speech
impediment I cannot it took me a long
time to get over saying things like
sista Soros properly so I I guess
I'd live with a slight Lisp thank you
would you rather chocolate or vanilla
chocolate yeah would you rather non-stop
peeing for the rest of your life or
non-stop crying for the rest of your
life well both of those kind of
interfere with daily life is it just
like a constant stream is it a trickle
is it just where's all this fluid coming
from I feel like I feel like this would
lead to a lot more problems than just
what's seen on the surface so do you
have to set up some kind of recycling
system so you don't become dehydrated I
guess I'll go with the being okay I'm
the unpopular one here okay good
would you rather be punched in the face
with brass knuckles by Mike Tyson or
punch a toddler and be seen by thousands
of people oh oh oh
but the first thought my brain went to
was oh that would get a lot of use if I
recorded this is where everyone
announces to their entire families
markiplier would rather punch a baby
because it could why do I feel bad I
blew up Detroit in the last one oh well
whatever would you rather have a drunk
personal driver or have a thieving maid
or nanny I figure I'd rather go with the
thieving nadir maid or nanny because
drunk driving is a terrible terrible
thing why why would you rather live to
be 120 and accomplish nothing notable or
live to be 50 and well-known for
world-changing accomplishments um yeah
the world-changing accomplishments duh
would you rather never watch baseball
again or never watch football again the
crisis of my sport fandom oh my
fantasies I don't give a [ __ ]
I guess baseball I don't know I don't
care I really don't care would you
rather eat Nutella or eat bacon bacon
bacon all the way bacon covered in
Nutella would be deadly for you or don't
do that
don't eat that Oh would you rather live
an average life and be forgotten and
timer go down
history for something terrible
markiplier is already punching toddlers
in the face and blowing it up Detroit
why not go down in his aah no ho be
remembered
oh god that's I guess Hitler was
remembered nevermind don't be remembered
would you rather eat the same thing
three meals a day for the rest of your
life or eat whatever you want but have
to eat a poop sandwich once a month oh
no oh this is a good one oh there's a
really good one oh do I eat the same
things that would get so boring but then
I could have whatever I want but I'd
have to eat a poop sandwich why can't I
live my life normally without the poop
ah I gotta go with the poop sandwich
really really you would go insane if you
had to eat this oh you would have to eat
the same three things if you would go
out of your goddamn mind but what if you
don't get the shoes what if it's a poop
sandwich you have to eat three meals a
day
ah you drive you absolutely bonkers
would you rather be James Bond or be
Jason Bourne
I gotta go with bond on this one this is
easy good brother be born let's see
would you rather be muscular with a
busted face or be busty with a gorgeous
face wait okay wait muscular with or
busty with a gorgeous I mean one of
these things is kind of it seems like I
gotta go with boobs I'm assuming that's
what it's talking about here I would
rather have boobs and a gorgeous face
seems like a win-win buy it boobs I just
play with them all day long oh would you
rather become a pokemon trainer or
attend Hogwarts okay so you guys know my
answer for this one it's pretty obvious
what I would pick but I'm gonna leave
this one up to you so answer in the
comments below I'd love to get your
input on which one you'd rather do and
you can play this game for yourself
through the link in the description
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know if you enjoyed this video I
really hope you did these are a lot of
fun for me to do I do hope to do another
will you press the button down in the
future and I'm gonna play a few more
flash games that have been very popular
like akinator and whatnot so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you
oh my god it's all different its new
like it let me know